forzando al gobierno chino a enfrentar sus problemas de contaminación.
China tiene ahora la oportunidad de convertirse en un líder ambiental global.
Pero el cuadro que les mostraré hoy
es uno que está mezclado.
Hay algunos signos muy prometedores,
y otras tendencias más problemáticas
y requieren de atención cuidadosa.
Pero ahora volvamos al relato.
Yo fui testigo de los inicios de la evolución verde en China.
En 2011, cuando estudiaba un doctorado y dirigía un trabajo de campo en China,
viajé a través de todo el país buscando respuestas a la pregunta
que usualmente me hago como extranjera escéptica:
¿Qué? ¿Dices que China está haciendo algo con su ambiente?
¿Tienen políticas ambientales?
¿Qué políticas?
En ese momento los datos PM 2,5 se consideraban muy sensibles politicamente
y el gobierno los mantenía en secreto.
Pero la población se estaba dando cuenta de los efectos dañinos a la salud humana,
y demandaban mayor transparencia
al gobierno.
De hecho, comencé a ver esa creciente evolución y conciencia yo misma
apareciendo por toda China.
La tiendas, por ejemplo, empezaron a vender purificadores de aire
que podían filtrar el dañino PM 2,5.
Los ciudadanos usaban el PM 2,5 como el título de un festival de música.
(Risas)
Y luego fui a un campo de golf en Shenzhen, en el sur de China.
Como pueden ver en este aviso, están anunciando una retirada del PM 2,5
debajo del índice para golf, pero no para respirar.
Luego el Bureau de Protección Ambiental de Shangai
decidió crear una mascota nombrada en mención al índice de calidad de aire
para comunicar mejor los datos sobre calidad de aire a su gente.
Yo la llame chica AQI,
y su expresión y color de ojos cambian dependiendo de la calidad del aire.
Cinco años después ella aún tiene la cara más sonriente
de Shangai.
Y luego, en 2015
el exreportero de la CCTV Chai Jimg
creó el documental "Debajo del domo",
comparable con la "Primavera Silenciosa" de Rachel Carson.
Y al igual que Rachel Carson
centró la atención en el hecho de que los pesticidas dañaban la salud humana.
"Debajo del Domo" se grabó en la conciencia popular
de que la contaminación del aire se cobraba un millón de muertes prematuras
cada año, solamente en China.
Este video acumuló
más de un millón de visualizaciones en un solo fin de semana
antes de que el gobierno de China,
temiendo que ello incitara algún tipo de disturbio social
lo sacara de internet.
Pero el daño ya estaba hecho.
La protesta pública por la contaminación
impulsó al gobierno de China,
quizás en un acto de autopreservación,
a pensar en grande y decididamente sobre cómo abordar
la raíz de su contaminación del aire
y muchos de sus otros problemas ambientales:
como su sistema de energía.
En China
cerca de dos tercios de su electricidad proviene del carbón.
China tiene más plantas de energía de carbón que cualquier otro país,
cerca del 40 % del total global,
y por eso el gobierno de China
desde 2014 ha decidido librar una batalla al carbón,
cerrando pequeñas minas de carbón,
imponiendo límites al consumo de carbón,
incluso cancelando una planta de energía de carbón australiana de gran importancia.
También está realizando grandes inversiones
en energía limpia y renovable,
como la hidráulica, la eólica y la solar.
Y el ritmo y la escala de esta transformación
ha sido absolutamente alucinante.
Les daré un par de estadísticas para mostrarles a lo que me refiero
En energía hidráulica, China lidera el mundo
con un tercio del total mundial.
Hay suficiente para cada ciudadano chino
para alimentar dos casas en un año, solo con energía hidráulica.
Quizás escucharon hablar de la Represa Tres Gargantas
imaginen,
esa es la central eléctrica más grande del mundo,
y funciona con agua.
En energía eólica,
China tiene la tercer parte de la capacidad global.
Esto la hace líder número uno de lejos.
Cuando miramos la energía solar, China también está al frente.
De hecho, ellos superaron su objetivo para el 2020
de instalar 105 gigawatts de energía solar.
Esto fue después de que el gobierno revisara y subiera
varias veces su objetivo sobre energía solar
entre 2009 y 2015.
El año pasado, en solo siete meses,
China fue capaz de instalar una friolera de 35 gigawatts de energía solar.
Esto es más que la mitad de lo que tiene EE. UU. combinando todo.
Y China lo hizo en siete meses.
Podemos observar este notable crecimiento en energía solar desde el espacio,
como lo hizo el proyecto SpaceKnow en esta diapositiva.
Hacia el 2020 China generará el consumo eléctrico de toda Alemania
solo proveniente de energía eólica y solar.
Esto es muy notable.
Y vemos ahora cierta evidencia
de que el esfuerzo de China a favor de la energía limpia
actualmente está mostrando sus efectos,
no solo en reducción de contaminación,
sino en el cambio climático global,
donde China tiene la huella más grande del mundo.
Al mirar la información, vemos que el consumo de carbón en China
puede haber llegado a su pico como en los principios de 2013.
Esta es la principal razón por la que el gobierno Chino anunciara
que actualmente ya ha alcanzado su promesa para 2020 de reducción de carbón
antes de lo previsto.
Esta reducción en el consumo de carbón
está también generando mejoras en la calidad del aire
en todo el país,
como he mostrado aquí en azul.
En grandes ciudades de China,
la contaminación del aire ha bajado hasta un 30 %.
La reducción en la contaminación está llevando a las personas
a tener vidas más largas en China,
en promedio dos años y medio más de lo que habrían tenido en 2013.
En amarillo, podemos ver las ciudades que han experimentado
las mayores mejoras en la calidad del aire.
Pero por supuesto, como mencioné al principio de esta charla,
tenemos que templar un poco este optimismo
con una dosis saludable de precaución
y eso es, en gran parte, porque los datos aún están siendo comprobados.
Al final del año pasado,
tras casi tres años de emisión global de carbón bastante estable,
las proyecciones científicas sugieren
que las emisiones quizás estén subiendo nuevamente
y eso puede ser debido al incremento en el consumo de combustible fósil en China.
Entonces quizás no hayan alcanzado el pico que les mostré antes.
Pero por supuesto, las estadísticas y la información aún son confusas
y eso es así porque China revisa sus estadísticas sobre carbón luego del hecho.
En realidad, esto es gracioso,
desde que estoy aquí he mantenido un debate en Twitter
con otros modeladores de clima,
tratando de ver si la emisión de carbón en China
ha subido, bajado o se mantiene estable.
Y por supuesto, China es aún un país con un desarrollo muy rápido.
Aún está experimentando con una gama de políticas,
como uso compartido de bicicletas,
que ha sido presentado como una solución de transporte sustentable.
Pero luego tenemos imágenes de este cementerio de bicicletas
que cuentan una historia aleccionadora.
A veces, las soluciones se mueven muy rápido
y superan la demanda.
Y por supuesto, el carbón aún es el rey en China,
al menos por ahora.
Y ¿por qué nos debiera importar lo que hace China por el ambiente?
Lo que este haciendo China en su casa, en el ambiente,
puede tener implicación global para el resto de nosotros.
Tomando una frase de Chai Jing,
estamos todos bajo el mismo domo,
y la contaminación del aire originada en China
puede viajar a través de su frontera
y afectar poblaciones tan lejanas como aquellas en América del Norte.
China no solo está exportando contaminación del aire,
también están exportando ayuda, infraestructura, tecnología.
El Presidente Xi Jinping anunció en 2013 la iniciativa One Belt, One Road,
un enorme proyecto de inversión en infraestructura de USD 1 billón
en más de 60 países.
Historicamente, cuando hemos visto
inversiones que China hizo en infraestructura en el exterior,
no siempre han sido limpias.
El Instituto Global del Ambiente, una asociación civil china,
fundada en los últimos 15 años,
ha invertido en más de 240 plantas de energía de carbón
en más de 68 países
afiliados a la iniciativa One Belt, One Road.
Eso es más que la cuarta parta de la capacidad de carbón doméstica de China
que se exporta al exterior.
Y vemos que, aún cuando China está limpiando la casa,
está exportando algo de esa contaminación
a otros países,
y las emisiones de gases invernadero simplemente no tienes pasaporte.
Y al tratar de evaluar esta cuestión
sobre si China está realmente liderando o no
podemos ver que aún es un debate abierto.
Pero el tiempo se está acabando.
He estudiado modelos climáticos, y la perspectiva no es buena.
Aún tenemos una brecha entre las políticas vigentes
y lo que debe suceder si queremos evitar el peligroso cambio climático.
Liderazgo es lo que necesitamos desesperadamente,
pero ello no vendrá de EE. UU.
El gobierno de EE. UU. anunció en junio su intención
de retirarse del Acuerdo Climático de París.
por eso la gente está mirando a China para llenar el vacío de liderazgo.
Por lo que China está sentado al mando
determinando el futuro de nuestro ambiente.
Lo que hacen con el comercio del carbón,
en energía limpia, en contaminación del aire,
podemos aprender varías lecciones.
Una enseñanza es que la energía limpia no solo es buena para el ambiente,
salva vidas al reducir la contaminación del aire.
Sirve también a la economía,
Podemos ver que en el último año,
China fue responsable del 30 % del crecimiento global
en trabajos verdes.
¿EE. UU.? Solo 6 %.
El panorama que acabo de mostrarles
por suerte parece muy diferente
de esas estadísticas turbias y oscuras del aire
hacia un panorama más claro de la energía limpia en China.
Y aunque China está orientada en la dirección correcta,
sabemos que todavía queda un camino largo por recorrer.
Y déjenme preguntarles una vez más: ¿Ver es creer?
¿Podemos creer los datos y estadísticas
que muestran que la calidad de aire de China está bajando
y que su guerra contra el carbón realmente está dando resultado?
Bueno, miremos algunas de las últimas imágenes satelitales
de las instalaciones de energía solar de China.
Quiero que miren detenidamente esta imagen.
¿Pueden verla?
La prueba puede estar en los pandas.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplauso)